why don't you ask the fans maybe i
should have to ask the fans where we
should get there i think that is a very
good idea
i have no idea where i want to get
married hey who needs a wedding planner
when you have the free britney movement
britney spears looked to her social
media brain trust with a very important
question following the pop icon and
longtime boyfriend sam askari announcing
their engagement last month look at that
you like it
the singer shared this tick tock on
tuesday featuring britney and her fiance
wearing these disney fight filters
before thinking about saying yes to a
dress britney wants to figure out where
to say i do why don't you ask the fans
maybe i should have to ask the fans
where we should get and i think that is
a very good idea
okay guys uh we have a predicament a
really big problem right now i have no
idea where i want to get married but hey
at least she has a short list we don't
know if we want to get married in italy
or greece australia or new york city
this all comes less than a week after
major change came to her life it's been
a lot of hard work
it's been intense
i'm proud
brittany is proud the court removed her
father jamie spears as conservator
setting in motion a likely end to the
entire conservatorship she of course is
engaged what does she want to do once
this conservative ship ends because you
fought so ferociously already to make
that happen well that's a good question
and what i would say to that is for the
first time in about 13 years
that decision will be up to britney and
only britney and that's a great thing
following the court's suspension of
britney's father her attorney assured
her supporters that his client was
celebrating i can't say where she is but
she's in a much nicer place than this
and she is on cloud nine and one week
later we know now that cloud nine
includes the south pacific and the
dessert cart
we're at this beautiful place in france
this is the french polynesia my children
had to tell me i mummy you and friends i
thought the french polynesia was
actually a different type of place oh my
god dinner was amazing because you know
why i got to leave early and i skipped
the show and i'm just gonna have dessert
in my room
brittany and sam's night out follows a
series of beach moments the couple
shared over the weekend
[Music]
including these not so safe for work
picks well trust me if we do ever get
married everybody's gonna know actually
you might be the first one to know
before popping the question with this
four carat diamond ring sam had been
quietly meeting with designers for
months eventually choosing roman malieve
to design the stunning rock it's just a
beautiful time in their lives and we're
just really thankful to be a part of it
[Music]
brittany and sam began dating after they
met on the set of her music video
slumber party and in 2019 he opened up
about their special bond i love the most
about my relationship is the fact that
it's it's so normal you know it's not
anything glad like you said it's not
glamorous or anything she inspires me in
my work and also i can give so much to
her by going to the gym by by going to
work by having an actual uh balanced
life you know we can get
inspired by each other here and there
and really grow with each other